pintât
nous on acheter on adore camping depuis
le début on est fan de frank dubosc et
oasis oasis super film c'est super
toujours aussi guerre génial j'ai perdu
ouais y'a rien à redire
la tête jusqu'au départ quand j'ai tapé
vanessa pour covoiturage c'était pas
pour tomber sur le tourisme c'est un
régal suis-je pas des chats vous êtes
des jeunes duléry les sensationnels les
films il était super et indien sont pas
donner de limite dans le froid et ça ne
comprends pas ce pas de deux du bowling
au bilboquet c'est que du bonheur j'ai
vraiment ri avec les tripes orange
pourrait que c'était le meilleur des 3
parce que franchement l'udps a de
l'humour
il ya un côté jeune tous pensent que je
vais leur demander à mes copines et
copains on espère que rennes 4e à les
voir comme un endroit